[Music]
do you want to know I've been arrested
six times is this the face of a arrested
six times man no I called I stopped
playing golf
I have to go safe meet the best one ever
was that I was at a I was in Lake Tahoe
and I was drunk at a bar and there was a
black man drinking at the bar and
because I was stupid and this is Lake
Tahoe I went up to him and I said I'm so
excited to see a person of color thank
Tom I was like the widest place in the
world is so nice to see you because I'm
from like a mixed part of Seattle I was
being sincere but I was also very drunk
and should not have been since uber
talked at all yeah but then I left that
party and a guy called the guy at the
party or at the bar he referred to him
later at a party as the n-word and so I
punched him I'm like a hero and then I
got kicked out of the party which was on
the top of a mountain and I was in a
t-shirt and jeans and there was 7 8 feet
of snow on the ground so I just started
walking down the hill
knocking on doors hoping to get in so
that I was not freeze to death for
fighting a racist
wait did that black man not come to us
we were we were head of bar I didn't say
I feel like this is confusing I did not
say the n-word I punched a guy for say
the friendly Negro didn't come to the
bar one of the houses I knocked on was a
house under construction so it did not
have a door I walked to the top floor
and then like mr. Magoo I walked
directly off the third floor into a
powder puff like a snow I got back up to
the road and when I got up to the road I
saw the cops because people had started
calling the cops because a guy was
banging on their door at 3:00 in the
morning when the cops showed up right
when I saw the cops I was soaked up in
cold I just turned to them and I went
like this and then I woke up from the
cops yeah they got handcuffs but when I
woke up in jail in the Truckee Truckee
City Jail who was my cellmate the black
man from the bar Annie Annie please
please tell me you didn't say it's so
good to see a black person
[Music]